Uhg, did you smell that guy?
Yeah, he reeked of marijuana.
Middle of the morning, what a shame.
This is just our culture now.
People think it's okay to just drug any time, any place.
Sick.  That's what they are.
I actually just finished a lengthy dissertation on this exact topic just last night.
How do you bang out these topical discourses so quickly, Oliver?  It is impressive.
"Bang out" is a rather violent way to describe my work, Jane.
True.  I apologize.
It's okay, but to answer your question, I just upped my Adderall dosage and then I just get my work done.
Genius.  I should actually try that.
You know I used to do that cause felt like so focused, you know
but then I lost my prescription--
Oh my god!  Look at that painting!
(gasps)
I once went to an art gallery and I took acid to like open up my mind--
Now see, doing drugs to open one's mind is totally acceptable.
Like I'll smoke a little J before going on stage to do an acoustic set
but it's not really for me, it's for the audience.
Soy Grande Mocha Latte Double-Shot Expresso with extra sugar.
Double Mocha coffee House Blend, one inch soy foam.
That's us.
(blowing)
It is disgusting when people use drugs as like "oh recreational activity."
Or like when they build like a dependency.
Exactly right.
Pathetic.
I'm sorry, uh, Atticus, did you not order something?
Oh, actually I was recently introduced to these caffeine pills.
They do the same thing coffee does but they don't waste the Earth's resources on water and cups.
What do you mean?
You guys both drink a cup of coffee a day, right?
Twice a day.
Three times!
So we're wasting all this water washing our cups
I mean think about it.  3 cups a day.  There's 3 of us.
There's 9 cups.
365 days in a year.
Since the invention and emergence of calculators I don't believe in wasting brain space on mathematics
but I will tell you that number is probably well in the thousands.
Uhg.
Weed man.
Pathetic.
Quit the addiction.